مع العلم أن إيران وروسيا تواجهان الآن
عقوبات من الولايات المتحدة من
الاتحاد الأوروبي أيضًا،
كيف ترى تأثير هذه
العقوبات على دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي وعلى
ألاباما؟
حسنًا، الوضع برمته مرتبك وغير مستقر
وديناميكي، لذا من الصعب قول
شيء ما  اليوم لن يكون هذا خطأً
غدًا ولكني سأحاول على أي حال بالتأكيد أن
الحرب بشكل عام تعطل
أسواق الطاقة العالمية وترفع
أسعار الطاقة في العالم بأكمله مما يعني المزيد من
الأموال في الخزانات على المدى القصير
وهذا حقًا ما حدث لـ
من ناحية أخرى، في هذه المنطقة مع كل
عدم الاستقرار العالمي، يصبح من الصعب
التخطيط لأن التوترات الجيوسياسية
أعلى لذا لا أستطيع أن أقول أن أي شيء
سهل للغاية فيما يتعلق بالوضع الحالي،
فدول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
مع كل ما يحدث حولها
تحاول التحرك أيضًا  من
الاعتماد على النفط إلى
الطاقة المستدامة والمتجددة، ما مدى صعوبة ذلك
في حين أن العالم كله يعيش في
فترة من عدم الاستقرار، فإن
هذا التحول الذي يتعين على العالم أن
يحدثه هائل ومعقد،
وهذه المنطقة تواجه تحديًا خاصًا بسبب
هذا لأن هذا هو العالم  مركز
الهيدروكربونات في الاقتصاد العالمي بأكمله،
لذا لا يوجد شيء سهل في هذا الأمر، ومن ناحية
أخرى، هناك الكثير من الجهد
بالطبع في الإمارات العربية المتحدة والمملكة العربية
السعودية في بلدان أخرى لقول ما
يمكننا القيام به وكيف يمكننا الاستفادة من الطاقة الشمسية على سبيل المثال  من
الواضح أنه
مورد ضخم آخر لهذه
المنطقة وهذا ما يحدث بالفعل، حيث يتم إجراء
تقنيات جديدة وأكبر منشآت الطاقة الشمسية
في العالم
هنا وتمويل جديد للبحث
والتطوير، كل هذا مثير للغاية ولكن
النقطة التي أوضحتها هي أيضًا في
غاية الأهمية وما هو مطلوب
الاستثمارات الضخمة التي ستربط
منطقة الخليج مع أوروبا والهند والصين
سواء كان ذلك في الهيدروجين أو في
الإلكترونات الخضراء لمسافات طويلة التي
تنتقل عبر مسافات طويلة
لنظام الطاقة المتجددة، يمكن أن يحدث هذا
ولكنك بحاجة إلى التعاون لذلك
تحتاج إلى الاستقرار الجيوسياسي لذلك نحن
لا نمتلكها الآن ولكننا بحاجة إليها
أعتقد أن أوروبا التي لديها اتفاقها الأخضر
يجب أن تتحدث مع دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي، قم
بتصدير بعض من أشعة الشمس إلينا
لأننا لا نملك نفس أشعة الشمس
التي لديك، فلنقم برحلة طويلة.  التزام طويل الأمد
معًا
ببنية تحتية كبيرة مترابطة، سيكون هذا
منطقيًا من وجهة نظري ولكن من الناحية الجيوسياسية
تقول أوروبا آه علينا أن نحمي
أنفسنا لذلك لا نريد أن نكون
متصلين أه انظر ما حدث
لخط أنابيب نوردستروم الذي كانت الولايات المتحدة في
التقارير الأخيرة هي السبب فيه  لقد
فجّر الأمر، فبالنظر إلى كل ذلك، من يتحدث
عن بنية البنية التحتية طويلة المدى
ولكننا نحتاج إليها، فهذه هي
المعضلة الحقيقية الآن، نحن بحاجة
إلى إيقاف هذه الحروب، نحتاج إلى
تعاون إقليمي كبير إذا أردنا
المضي قدمًا  لإنجاز
كل الأشياء التي يتعين علينا إنجازها، لكن
لسوء الحظ، فإن القادة السياسيين منغمسون
في الحرب والصراع قصير المدى أكثر من
اهتمامهم بحل المشكلات طويلة المدى،
ما هي التداعيات إذا
استمرت الأمور كما هي الآن، ما هي
التداعيات التي تقول في  بعد مرور 10 سنوات
على الموسم، إذا وقفنا على هذا المسار من
الصراع، أعتقد أننا لا نستطيع المبالغة في تقدير
المخاطر لأننا لسنا في
صراع مستمر فحسب، بل في
صراع متصاعد، انظر إلى الحرب في
أوكرانيا كل شهر أو شهرين ماذا  كان من
المفترض أن يكون الحد الأقصى للتسلح
قد تم تجاهله أوه لا لا لا دبابات حسنًا
دبابات أوه لا لا طائرات مقاتلة من يدري
ربما الطائرات المقاتلة مستمرة في
تصعيد خطير نفس الشيء
يحدث في شرق آسيا نفس الشيء
يحدث في هذا  تصعيد الخطاب
خطير للغاية بشأن تايوان على سبيل
المثال، لا أريد أن أرى تايوان هي
أوكرانيا التالية حيث تندلع الحرب
بين قوتين عملاقتين ولكن هذا
ما هو على المحك الآن ليس
فقط استمرار المواجهة وخسارة
كل المكاسب  التعاون ولكن
في الواقع مخاطر
التصعيد الخطير للغاية ما هي
أفكارك حول أه
عالم الأجيال الحالية دولار
إنهم يواجهون العديد من التحديات إنهم
يواجهون البطالة يواجهون العديد من
التحديات الأخرى ماذا سيحدث في
السنوات القادمة لهذه الأجيال إذا كانت
الأمور  استمر كما هو الآن،
أود أن أقول لجيل الشباب
في أي مكان سواء كان ذلك في
دول الخليج أو المنطقة العربية أو
الولايات المتحدة أو في البرازيل حيث كنت
قبل أسبوعين،
احصل على تعليم جيد لأن العالم
معقد.
سوف تحتاج إلى مهارات لأعمالك
المستقبلية،
وسوف تبحث فقط
إما عن أشخاص ذوي مهارات أو أشخاص
لديهم نوع من العمل الوحشي
الذي لا يشكل مستقبلًا، وبالتالي فإن التعليم
في رأيي هو النقطة الأولى
وذلك لأننا  نحن في
عصر مدفوع للغاية بالعلوم والتكنولوجيا
لأن العالم معقد ولأن
الهياكل الاقتصادية القديمة
معطلة بشدة، فسوف يتغيرون من
يعرف ما الذي سيحدث في المستقبل
ولكن امتلاك المهارات سيكون
ضروريًا من وجهة نظر الفرد  وجهة
نظر أو وجهة نظر جيل